so you would carry a dead baby for the  last three months of your pregnancy or  if I misunderstood no after six months  so after six months the baby can survive  outside the womb in a um yes so then  they'll you give birth to the baby and  put the baby in the incubator Force the  pregnancy  so abortion won't save that woman's  alive because that's a two-day procedure  so there's there's this there's a lot of  these lies that have been going going  around that are put out by the abortion  industry things like even the stats that  they said we're going to go back to  Backstreet abortions they were conflated  and it's been proven by abortionists the  the guy who came up with those stats  he's now changed and he's now pro-life  and he's yeah and the book guy um in and  you can Google it I've forgotten his  name apologies but but they said that  these stats were made up